yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Marvel continues its tradition of
teasing us upcoming movies in the MCU
with two extra scenes and dr. Strange's
credits in this video I'm going to break
down the movies mid-credits scene and
explain some of its easter eggs and just
to be very clear there are spoilers for
both Doctor Strange itself and an
upcoming Marvel movie in this video so
if you want to avoid those you can watch
my spoiler free review of Doctor Strange
here and come back and watch this video
after you've seen the movie okay after
the initial set of fancy credits roll we
get a funny scene between Doctor Strange
and SAW who have sitting in stranger's
sanctum sanctorum in New York
Thor comments that earth now has wizards
strange then offers thought a cup of tea
but Thor refuses saying he doesn't drink
tea and strange magically makes a very
large glass of beer appear instead this
moment is a nice callback to the scene
in the first Saw movie where the
Asgardian God and Erik Selvig drink a
boilermaker in a bar from a similar
sized glass and of course we also know
from that movie that it's coffee that
Thor likes not tea but what is Thor
doing with dr. strange here well if you
think back to the last time we saw Thor
he was at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron when he left the Avengers saying
he was going back to Asgard to
investigate the visions he had of the
Infinity stones well it's likely that
saw heard about what strange did in this
movie and might even be were that he has
access to the time stone this meeting
between the two characters links to the
sword Ragnarok set photo that was
tweeted showing Chris Hemsworth holding
up a card that reads a hundred and
seventy seven eight Bleecker Street
which is the address of dr. Strange's
sanctum sanctorum so back to the mid
credit scene
strange explains to Thor that he keeps a
watch list of individuals and beings
from other realms that could be a threat
to earth and he points out that Thor's
brother Loki is on that list
Thor agrees that Loki is indeed a worthy
inclusion on the list something of
course we know ourselves from all the
shenanigans low he's got up to in the
MCU so far particularly the events of
the Avengers movie strange then asked
why bring Loki to New York to which Thor
replies that he and Loki are looking for
their father Odin strange asks Thor if
they find Odin whether they'll all
return to Asgard promptly Thor agrees
that they will so strange confirms he'll
help him to understand this scene best
we need to roll back to the events of
Thor the dark world and remember that at
the very end of that movie Loki has
taken over the throne in Asgard mask
Odin since that film even though Thor
appeared in age of Ultron it still
hasn't been revealed that Thor knows
what Loki has been up to even though we
the audience know which suggests that
this mid-credits scene is a snippet of a
scene from the Thor Ragnarok rather than
a separate standalone scene shot just
for the Doctor Strange movie after all
this scene was filmed by Ragnarok
director Taika Waititi rather than
Doctor Strange director scott derrickson
i think the last time this happened was
with the post-credits scene for ant-man
which t is a short clip with Bucky
Captain America and Falcon from Captain
America Civil War all of this means that
it looks like Thor is going to uncover
Loki's ruse back on Asgard early on in
Thor Ragnarok and that they will then
team up with Doctor Strange to search
for the missing Odin and it also
confirms that as well as Doctor Strange
appearing in Avengers infinity war in
2018 will be seeing Benedict Cumberbatch
back in another Marvel movie in 2017 so
that was the mid credit scene from
Doctor Strange which I thought was good
fun and a nice tease for 2017 s Thor
movie I especially like the way that
Thor's beer glass kept filling up by
magic with more beer must get myself one
of those glasses but now I'd love to
know what you think about Doctor Strange
teaming up with saw next year and
Ragnarok and let me know if you got any
predictions about what will see them get
up - and don't forget there is a second
post-credit scene - which I'm going to
discuss in this video here and I've also
got a giveaway for this cool book about
Marvel's Doctor Strange coming very
shortly so make sure you're subscribed
and you've got your notifications on for
flicks in the city you can also check
out my fall's Doctor Strange playlist
which includes videos on all the Easter
eggs and Doctor Strange my move review
WTF facts and cast interviews click on
any of the links below to see those if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
subscribe share and like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers